sie wissen wie es auf der Straße zugeht
wie sie wissen genau wie in diesen
Vierteln gesprochen wird wie viel
Respekt hat man vor den deutschen
Polizisten
in erster Linie ich glaube schon dass
die Jugendlichen Respekt haben vor der
Polizei die haben schon Respekt aber
so ein Abend wenn die sich zusammentun
dann fühlen die sich mutig und dann
machen sie Dummheiten das sind einfach
Jugendliche Freizeit haben im Leben und
nicht wissen wie ihre Zukunft anzufangen
immer so warum ist der Mensch dazu in
der Lage sowas zu machen also ich bin
auf jeden Fall dagegen das ist nicht gut
was in Berlin passiert ist und auch auf
jeden Fall was gegen die Feuerwehr
passiert ist oder gegen die Polizei aber
was hat sie dazu geführt ich will meiner
Meinung ist die Gruppe und der Aufmarsch
der Polizei hat zusammen mobilisiert
durch die Angst dass sie so reagiert
haben die haben psychische psychologisch
haben sie sich zusammengetan und aus
Angst Dummheiten gemacht hätte der
Fraktionschef von Parteichef der von
cdu/csu bzw der CDU Parteivorsitzende
Friedrich Merz der hat auch diese
Debatte geführt und der hat ein ganz
klares Wort benannt für diejenigen die
dort seiner Meinung nach auf der Straße
waren immer ganz kurz rein
sprechen Sie mal mit Lehrerinnen und
Lehrern in den Grundschulen was die
jeden Tag erleben auch an verbaler
Gewalt und dann wollen Sie diese Kinder
zur Ordnung rufen und die Folge ist dass
die Väter in den Schulen erscheinen und
sich das verbitten insbesondere wenn es
sich um leere Rinnen handelt dass sie
ihre Söhne die kleinen Paschas damals
etwas
zurechtweisen da fängt es an
der CDU und CSU-Fraktionschef Friedrich
Merz über diejenigen die seine Meinung
nach eben kein Respekt vom Rechtsstaat
haben in dem Fall vor den Lehrern vor
den vor allen Dingen Lehrerinnen haben
er frei bei uns im Studio der Kollege
von Friedrich Merz hier auf diesem Stuhl
hat er recht damit mit diesem Begriff
auch Paschas also jedenfalls hat
Friedrich März einen Sachverhalt
beschrieben der bedauerlicherweise in
Deutschland Realität ist denn ich möchte
es noch mal sagen es geht hier nicht um
Dummheiten es geht um fehlenden Respekt
vor den Sicherheitskräften auch vor den
Institutionen unseres Staates und es hat
natürlich in vielen Fällen schon etwas
auch mit Integration zu tun genau diesen
Respekt zu haben übrigens den Respekt
nicht nur vor den Institutionen sondern
beispielsweise auch vor Polizistinnen
oder vor Lehrerinnen weil man das anders
gelernt hat sagt Friedrich Merz Manuel
mammutschar Paschas sagt der Friedrich
Merz da bei meinem Kollegen Markus Lanz
sind sie ein Pascha
allein die Aussage ist doch schon falsch
also es tut mir leid wir reden
ist es nicht Vorbild
der Kamera die Jugendlichen wenn sie
sich beleidigt dadurch ich kann mich
erinnern dass in der U-Bahn ganz andere
Begriffe fallen hier in Berlin
das ist die Straße das ist das Leben so
wie die Jugendlichen aufgewachsen sind
wenn man ich bin ja damals 1989 nach
Deutschland eingelassen Flüchtling
damals hatte ich nicht die Möglichkeit
gehabt die heute die Flüchtlinge so ein
gutes Leben zu haben direkt eine
Ausbildung zu machen schulische Hilfe
und alles damals war die Politik noch
sehr streng und anders damit
verlassen und wenn das verlassen wollte
ein anderes Bundesland
einreisen möchte braucht jemand
Erlaubnis das hat mich sehr sehr schwer
behindert in meiner sportlichen Karriere
da ich als ich Kickboxen war ich konnte
damals keine Angst Turniere mit
teilnehmen in Europa weil ich keine
Ausweis hatte auch als Profiboxer wurde
es mir sehr sehr schwer gemacht ich bin
trotzdem geblieben auch wenn ich
wirklich schwere Zeiten hat leben oder
auch mit falsche
Menschen oder Gruppen Umgang
bin ich trotzdem
zwischen der Straße
weil sie ärgert noch einmal dieses Wort
vom Pascha Herrscher gibt Situationen in
ihrer Kindheit in der Schulzeit mit der
Lehrerin oder auf der Straße mit
Polizistin wo sie sicher erinnern sie
selber haben auch Kontakt mit der
Polizei immer wieder mal gehabt dass sie
sich ein bisschen ertappt fühlen in dem
was Friedrich Merz sagt und sagen ja mit
mist da habe ich nicht ausreichend
Respekt gehabt nein ich habe ich habe
immer das Gefühl auch wenn ich
Dummheiten gemacht habe selber als
Jugendlicher ich war nicht recht also
ich habe nie beleidigt oder
aggressiv geworden so wirklich Mist
geworden
in Berlin ich weiß nicht wie das dort
läuft aber ich kann für mich sprechen
ich war niemals ein Gesicht zur
Polizisten
damit ansprechen wollen ganz offenbar
dieses Problem dass dort Kinder
Jugendliche sind die aus ihrer Familie
durch ihre Herkunft ganz andere
Erfahrungen mit Sicherheitskräften
gemacht haben Erfahrungen die wir hier
in Deutschland auf keinen Fall machen
wollen wo die Polizei wo das Militär
viel härter viel brutaler durchgreift
können Sie da verstehen dass man weniger
Respekt hat vor den Kollegen von Herrn
nientro wenn die Polizei erstmal
deskalieren beispielsweise Auftritt also
dass man eben diesen Respekt eben nicht
lebt auf den Straßen also ich glaube
dass diese Debatte gerade mit Pascha und
diese das ist für mich eine
ablenkungstebatte und mit einem klaren
rassistischen Einschlag und selbst
Lindner hat sich von diesen Äußerungen
distanziert und gesagt die CDU ist
deswegen nicht regierungsfähig die
Grünen haben sich hier gesagt sie werden
keine Koalition mit dazu du eingehen
aufgrund dieser debat nicht finde wir
sollten schon über die richtigen Sachen
sprechen und jetzt nicht irgendwelche
ablenkungsdebatten führen also ähm mein
Sohn beispielsweise hört das ähm
respektloses Verhalten gegenüber
Lehrerin von allen möglichen
Schülerinnen und das liegt nicht äh also
dieses Problem sozusagen zu etisieren
finde ich falsch ja also das ist kein
ethnisch begründetes Problem das einfach
es gibt ein Problem natürlich mit
Menschen auch Familien die überfordert
sind die sich nicht ausreichend
vielleicht um den Kindern nicht
ausreichend die Möglichkeiten geben und
bildungsschancen und so weiter also wir
haben da eine ganze Menge Probleme und
das hat sicher auch was mit Respekt zu
tun und ich finde wenn wir wollen und
wir wollen das ist mehr Respekt gibt vor
der Demokratie und staatlichen
Einrichtungen dann müssen wir Projekte
Stärken wie gewaltpräventionsprojekte
das machen wir übrigens in Berlin mit
der Landeskommission gegen Gewalt wir
müssen Sozialarbeit stärken und all
diese Sachen und es geht auch darum dass
Menschen beispielsweise das ist jetzt
keine täteropfer Umkehr oder irgendeine
Verharmlosung ganz sicher nicht aber man
muss sich die Ursachen angucken und es
gibt Menschen die haben beispielsweise
kein Vertrauen oder ein Misstrauen in
Strukturen weil sie merken dass sie
benachteiligt und ausgegrenzt werden das
heißt dieser Studien das haben Familie
zu lassen ich glaube niemanden hier die
Sozialarbeiter
gehen wir viel zu wenig wir haben einen
Gipfel gegen Jugend Gewalt gemacht
Franziska Giffey hat dazu eingeladen und
da festgestellt worden nein wir haben
verabredet dass wir Millionen wieder wir
haben ja schon Sozialarbeit in meinem
Wahlkreis kann ich nur empfehlen Gangway
die machen ganz tolle Straßen
Sozialarbeit und viele Jugendarbeit und
es gibt Projekte und es ist eine
Verabredung noch etwas zu tun
möglicherweise nach der Wahl ja gut wir
haben ja erste Schritte also er
beispielsweise es ging vorhin um Justiz
und schnelle Verfahren unter rot grün
rot wurden am meisten Personal in der
Justiz eingestellt wie jemals zuvor auch
nicht unter einer CDU mit mit Regierung
ich will sagen wir tun ganz viel und wir
tun auch aktuell viel Verfahren laufen
es gibt viel Prävention soweit aber wir
wollen sie sterben aber man muss auch
immer Sachen reden
es vermischt sich sehr sehr viel und wir
können gerne Pascha Debatte führen und
wir müssen auch darüber sprechen dass es
vermehrt auch unter dem Jahr zu
Angriffen aus Jugendgruppen gibt auch
oftmals mit Migrationshintergrund vor
Halloween alles Gute
die Tasche Debatte zielt darauf dass
Herr März damit ausdrücken wollte ganz
offenbar es geht hier um Respekt es geht
um mangelnde komme
vollkommen recht das hat im übrigen Herr
freies tut mir leid aber hat die
Berliner CDU in den Jahren als in
Regierung Verantwortung war auch nicht
gebucht bekommen ja die Probleme die wir
heute haben die sind nicht erst unter
rot grün rot oder rot rot grün
entstanden sondern die sind schon Jahre
vorher gewachsen was uns ein bisschen
stört ist wir machen jetzt ein
Jugendgewalt Gipfel alles schön bisschen
Schnittchen Essen super die Probleme
können mir seit 15 Jahren und wir wissen
auch was wir tun müssen wenn wir darüber
reden dass jetzt nach Silvester die
Strafen ganz schnell kommen müssen wegen
Gewalt gegen Einsatzkräfte bin ich als
Gewerkschafter der für Polizistinnen und
Polizisten und Feuerwehrleute spricht
voll mit dabei aber darauf hat auch eine
Frau unter dem Jahr den Anspruch die
Opfer einer häuslichen Gewalt wurde und
das passiert eben auch nicht und wenn
wir darüber reden wir möchten die
Sozialarbeit Stärken also vor ihrer
kennenzulernen oder Friedrich mein
Kreuzberg wir können ja mal gucken wie
in den bezogen wie viele Stellen für
Sozialarbeiter leer sind weil wir die
Leute gar nicht finden und noch mal Herr
Schaar riesen Respekt ja was Boxkarriere
angeht aber Fakt ist in Deutschland gibt
es auch keine Friedensrichter ja und sie
haben sich ja auch schon mal hingestellt
und wollten vermitteln im Bereich der
organisierten Kriminalität das heißt
wenn wir über Respekt reden und das ist
auch ein Faktor wie greifen Menschen an
Polizei und Feuerwehr zum einen weil sie
die greifen können anders als in der
freischaufe nicht dass sie angegriffen
werden aber sie sind Bundespolitiker in
Verantwortung an den kann ich meinen
Frust nicht ablassen an den
Sicherheitskräften die auf der Straße
sind schon und bei der Rechtsstaat und
da sind wir bei dem Faktor dann wenn wir
über junge Menschen mit
Migrationshintergrund oder Ausländer an
sich sprechen in vielen Heimatländern
wird für verhältnismäßig kleinere
Delikte eben viel härter abgeschlossen
und Kreuzbergs oder im Wedding
möglicherweise hier Scharia mehr Geld
als der Rechtsstaat der deutschen
mittlerweile wissen sie am 16.09 in
Hellersdorf ein Böller aus dem Balkon
geschmissen das war niemand mit
Migrationshintergrund ja ähm wir haben
während der corona-zeit
die Frage ist ob es schlimmer geworden
ist und ich glaube das ist keine
deutschen wir reden jetzt darüber aber
während der coronazeit wir diverse
Angriffe aus Gruppen in Parks gehabt wo
junge Leute zusammengekommen sind ja
jetzt kann man sagen ja die durften ja
während der coronazeit nichts machen ne
aber Fakt ist die trinken Alkohol die
konsumieren drogenachter ist ein
Polizist nach den schmeiße ich jetzt mal
voll so und den attackiert das heißt wir
müssen schon die Debatte führen über was
was ihr eigentlich Silvester passiert
ist und wir reden nur darüber weil wir
Bilder sehen wie Einsatzkräfte
angegriffen werden also reden wir mal
darüber wie war das verbessern können
und da geht's um starken Rechtsstaat da
geht so ein Respekt und es geht aber
auch wie lebe ich das als Politik vor
Stärke ich meiner Polizei den Rücken
oder mache ich bei jedem Fehlverhalten
such wirklich nach dem absoluten Fehler
und macht dann Generalverdacht wir
wollen nicht ein Generalverdacht über
junge Leute mit Migrationshintergrund
stehen ich erwarte aber auch dass nicht
alle Beschäftigten der Polizei in Berlin
in eine Schublade geschickt werden wenn
sich mal einer daneben benimmt und genau
das passiert ich meine wir haben ein
landesdiskriminierungsgesetz in Berlin
das ist sonst sonst anderen
und da wird werden die Polizisten
natürlich unter General Verdacht
gestellt und müssen sozusagen im Wege
der Beweislastumkehr nachweisen dass sie
nicht diskriminiert haben
das ist etwas was absolut indiskutabel
ist und was im Grunde genommen einfach
nur zeigt dass man denen die eigentlich
für Recht und Ordnung sorgen mit
Misstrauen begegnen
nicht ernst nimmt zeigt den Finger schon
ja es gibt ja die ganze Zeit schon hier
ein bisschen
es ist schon ein bisschen gefährlich
diese Debatte die man momentan für
das mit dem Migrationshintergrund und
Täter und was momentan auch warum ist
das gefährlich weil wir genau den Leuten
zu arbeiten mit dieser Debatte die im
Problem mit unserer Demokratie haben die
kriegen dann auch noch recht glauben sie
dass sie gar nicht ich glaube wir haben
ja jetzt gar nicht darüber gesprochen
aber das ist die Tendenz die die
Jugendliche erleben so das ist die
Tendenz es gibt jetzt diesen
Generalverdacht und da denke ich mal
mehr wert diesen Generalverdacht ich
höre immer das Wort von von ihrer Seite
und ich habe niemanden gehört der
Generator von deutschen Beschuldigten
fragen was macht man denn dann das ist
keine ordentlichen deutschen oder was
ist das das Problem also warum fragt man
nach den Vornamen gesagt man muss es
immer im Kontext
der Zeit sehen und damals hat man über
die falschen Themen gesprochen dieser
Antrag hat schon den Zweck gedient
Transparenz in die Debatte zu bringen
das ist ja ganz offensichtlich
da kann ich was sagen die Berliner CDU
hat ja selber eingesehen Herr Freitag
das Problem ist natürlich die Frage
ergibt nur Sinn wenn ich die Antwort
bekomme die ich vorher möchte und wir
müssen aufpassen schaffen wir
populistisch rassistische Restaurants
oder was passiert wenn ich mit der CDU
Berlin spreche und man hat selber
eingesehen
haben Moment den Namen und dann sage ich
na Warzen wissen Sie was dann kommt da
kommt nicht
mal war auch keiner aus Hellersdorf
Marzahn waren Touristen sehen diese
Debatte wenn einem irgendetwas nicht
passt dann spricht man sofort von
rassistisch Rassismus doch auf der
anderen brauchen wir auch keine schönen
Malerei wie es auch und auf der anderen
Seite passiert die einen sagen ja das
ist eine wir müssen eine Debatte über
Migranten die anderen sagen die sind
nicht Migranten alles schön sprechen wir
über das was wir wissen das machen wir
sachlich und es gibt nur das einmalige